yeah welcome to this video five minute
game against the tactic freak and with
some moves order switch we come to the
open Sicilian wanted some dragon an
accelerated dragon job is playing
instantly of course I'm simply amazed is
this a book line or whatever and he's
playing this in ten seconds or whatever
maybe he's thinking that this is a
bullet game
yeah well anyway um but what can i play
him d5 is some it's not so easy to to
keep he's some probably I'm going to
take it next month I'm not sure Bishop
Bishop g5 or Bishop f4 some moves like
this but at the end he's very active
yeah the the fun thing is what what he
played then ten seconds is actually good
so great at least I don't don't see the
big idea at the moment to to respond to
his to his Salaam
get this pressure on c2 was is really
annoying
yeah I'm so much down on the clock it's
it's amazing
he's just playing instantly and it
doesn't seem to be a big bad really
okay I need to get the see porn out of
autofocus from this this this bishop
yeah this I can just take the five no
take the five and take your seven or
something and maybe this is not not
leading to much okay I can also just
retreat
Bishop t5a H takes M G was the problem
what this is this is good at what just
giving away e7 cannot cannot believe
that this er this should be playable
I've been taking f7 now and also night
eggs f5 absolutely destroys the spawn
structure this is also Fred maybe he
needs to go up it should be six now on
96 well 96 I can simply take awesome
yeah I'm down to 140 form I mean this
guy really irritated with his instant
moves I must admit that I absolutely
hate if they move instantly but okay
it's nothing you can you can do
something about all right so just take
it you know I need to I need to gain
gain some speed here the eight is also
on three seven
I'd like to play I'm relatively simple
and simple moves yeah
let's sound make sure that I've got some
room for the king and okay p7 was also
hanging but I can also just make Reece
the pressure on the upon there okay this
is probably giving black chances to draw
but I can I can at least move quickly
here also you never know what kind of
moves the opponent is coming up with
ah huh interesting
okay I want I want them on the left palm
I'm free at porn
it's can always go to juicing Center
okay
don't mind okay the question is what
take now cooking me five he's taking
this porn so this side this doesn't help
not sure yet how to how to play this
would be nice to have a bit more time
but okay so nothing can be done at the
moment about this must combine here the
pants
I'm warning ya I'm just going to be
seven let's see what he's going to do
about that this is also a porn your
whites just winning okay oops
oh no slip okay that's it's a win anyway
yeah the easiest is to get the the H
porn also to a queen just no stay
inmates please yeah no is investing time
really the first couple of moves were
more difficult yeah of course I spent
far too much time so it really got hairy
but if you move instantly all the time
it's probably it's a very problem that
you make some some mistakes yeah this is
rather typical letting the clock run
down last 40 seconds alright so this was
some our problematic around here think
there's not so much going on really all
the computer actually thinks why does so
much better here because of the these
problems in the center yeah after age
six it wants to take on f5 but this also
must be good yeah now just rookie seven
and white winsome alright thanks for
watching